greetings planeswalkers
i'm adam mattini design lead for magic
legends and today
i'm excited to give you a breakdown of
the highly requested brand new gear
system
otherwise known as equipment in magic
legends
through our closed alpha tests in 2020
we gathered a lot of player feedback
that while our spell and artifact loot
was an interesting approach to player
progression in the magic multiverse
these features couldn't fully replace a
gear system in an action rpg
so we took another pass at our
itemization to develop a gear system
that makes defeating enemies and
completing missions
that much more rewarding while avoiding
overbearing loot drops and inventory
management
magic legends will feature six slots for
equipment allowing planeswalkers to
improve character stats and collect new
appearances
your characters will be able to mix
match and maximize pieces of gear for
their head
body arms and feet as well as two
accessory slots
equipment pieces come in four rarities
common uncommon rare and mythic rare
just like tabletop magic the stat
bonuses from equipment will focus on
improving overall combat ability and
survivability
through effects like increased damage
potency mana color specific damage
reduction
soul stealing to consume the life force
of fallen enemies to name just a few
beyond these basic stat bonuses
equipment will provide triggered effects
through their mods
which synergize with spells and
artifacts deepening the level of loadout
customization
for example i've just completed a
mission and earned the nemesis mask as a
reward
i've now unlocked a usable gear piece
and its appearance in the tailor
by default this item has three mods its
core mod grants a percent chance to
taunt enemies when i damage them while
at full health it also has two adaptive
mods one of which increases my
resistance to blue mana spells and
enemies
and another that increases the potency
of health globes
my core mod for taunting enemies will
have a significant impact when combined
with something like the molten shell
spell
and the geomancer's melee centric
ability kit as i'm receiving shield over
my health bar
and dealing a lot of damage up close to
enemies who are forced to continually
attack
all gear you collect is a single core
mod and one or more adaptive mods
core mods are fixed and cannot be
swapped out while adaptive mods can be
interchanged
to keep your equipment collection
focused duplicate pieces of gear
don't need to be sold to a vendor
instead you will either unlock a new
adaptive mod or earn an
upgrade material for that specific piece
of equipment
these materials can then be used to
improve the stats of a
mod on that equipment for example after
defeating some enemies i have just
received another nemesis mask
i see that this particular version of
the nemesis mask has an adaptive mod
for plus secondary ability potency which
i didn't have before
so i've now unlocked this adaptive mod
and can choose to replace the existing
blue mana resistance with this brand new
secondary ability potency
in that first adaptive mod slot
aside from stats everyone knows that
looking cool is the greatest way to
increase your character's effectiveness
in magic legends equipment not only
gives you access to a wide variety of
items for enhanced performance
but it also unlocks new cosmetic options
to access your unlocked appearances and
update your outfit
simply visit a tailor found in the hub
area of each region
in addition to costume changes the
tailor also allows for adjustments to a
character's body
face skin color hairstyle and more
with this new equipment system
complementing deck building and
artifacts
preparing planeswalker loadouts is an
even deeper experience and we're so
excited for you all to start
theorycrafting incredible builds
we've got more awesome stuff coming as
we prepare for open beta
so make sure to follow us on our socials
for all the latest news and updates on
magic legends
i'll see you in the multiverse